hey whats up its 2015 turns out it's
pretty great year for video games six
months and we had some great video games
this year blood-borne the witcher 3 wild
hunt you pick one rajbhandari you said
Witcher I sure did um Peter Brant well
dude stitute it's pretty great you
kidding me is all we're gonna come up
with all I've been playing is what
you're right you're just looking at
forward is that it I've been playing you
just looking for Gilead yeah oh yeah
case in point this deers moving pretty
good forget the witcher 3 is pretty good
but the rest of you here looks even
better dude looks even better between
now I think the time we celebrate that
little nazareth ii and baby thing it's
gonna be fits it's off the chain I don't
got a whole is I've oldest the games uh
they're coming add that we can be
excited for do you find a good through
because they're in alphabetical order
please no [ __ ] starring chronological
order starting august 3rd with rare
replay yes I'm common rare games going
back banjo kazooie and viva pinata and
so on perfect dark no golden eye but you
know the rest of us you excited for that
an owner's perfect dark I absolutely
loved that was like the nice segue out
of gold and i right like mmm this is
golden i just a little more futuristic
pro-am xin it Conker's Bad Fur Day
there's a lot of good stuff in the 8-bit
era as well which has some of the best
music out of rare I'm stoked about that
actually fun august 3rd to get you
warmed up to a crazy August in September
volumes at August eighteenth Mike
Bithell second game then we've got gears
of war Ultimate Edition on august twenty
fifth and on that same day we've madden
16 and until dawn any hot takers for
until dawn I've played that a couple of
times no love it no just can't wait to
put more it's okay it's got a hayden
penitent troop it Patera is Hayden
Hayden pity player potentially a pay
pedo pedo Tron Hayden pay the Tron and
that's gonna be interesting to read the
reviews of that one cuz it could go
either way looking forward to it there
she is she
it's like trying to go for just like a
CD me I like it is going all the way
with like it's like night trap but 2015
[ __ ] and moving swiftly on the
next week once you're finished playing
on till dawn and metal gear solid 5 the
phantom pain yeah you're pretty psyched
about that yeah I'm pretty psyched about
it I played a lot of that game already
and I it can't not come soon enough soon
enough tell us things med the game
you're not let say god I wish I could
you play as a child soldier no although
the only reason I'm buying the game I
can't I can't talk about Chelsea Tina
you can you know they talk about saw
soldiers and I talk about why you bags
or buy all your head no doubt legs are
is the revenge in it yes revenge is the
central plot of the game revengeance
whoa there's so many things I want to
talk about this is actually like kind of
painful really I'm sorry is it killing
me we're all excited about it there's
Afghanistan never looks so beautiful
real time with her OD [ __ ] oh that's
real that's not very real that was the
best porn add the same day that's coming
out September first bad max is coming
out yeah that was a badly timed yes
situation yeah I mean who knows we but
it looks I was surprised by like when
the last gameplay trailers they had you
know they showed off some cool stuff
like you no soup up your car and hit the
desert Oh your magnum opus yeah yeah I'm
talking about fixing up here look it's
exactly the same you and zeros except
you've got a magnum opus in cetera or
some Chum Bucket writing in the bag
that's his name humbug humbug get
straight up yes your bucket rate up you
when you see the nighttime scenes you'll
know why he's called Chum Bucket hey I
wonder if this has got real time weather
real-time shown you're looking go can't
wait for that Avalanche Studios got two
games coming out this year we'll talk
about the second one later at September
11 Super Mario maker hidden the wii u
one of the only big wii u games coming
out hell yeah looking forward to that I
am there's a huge community of people
that mod the original super mario world
and they have made crazy [ __ ] over the
past like 10-15 years and to actually
have official tools and ways to share
that stuff online it's gonna be great I
think the e3 stuff really sold me on
that I didn't really care about
for but the Nintendo World Championships
were pretty fun we were watching the
stream in the games about a war room
that was odd that was all right and
moving swiftly on September 15th we got
forza motorsport 6 mighty number 9 and
again I know you guys are really excited
about pro volution soccer 2016 right
mighty number 9 Peter I know you're a
big fan yeah I'm I've played a little
bit of it when it was like started like
the early beta stuff and it was good but
but I felt like crap it's not different
enough from megaman that I'm gonna be
really amped to finish it so I want to
see what they've done in the meantime
I've know they've added new levels and
such but I wanted there's god there's
something missing there's an element of
it that wasn't there so I'm curious to
see it it'll be good to see if I'm
finally fully playable after the the
Kickstarter love was at all take it was
only last year i think it's been oh it's
been a while using 82 years eyes are
really yeah two years yeah it'll be
interesting to finally see that they're
one of the sort of early kick star or
sort of second wave kick star successes
moving on September 20th Skylanders
supercharged said 22nd FIFA 16 and tony
hawk pro skater 5 is at September 25th
is it really gonna come out that time
yeah it's kind of crazy I'd like I don't
know we haven't seen anything have we
there was a bit of gameplay they showed
on Jeff Keeley stage at e3 but like not
one bad at my job very different like it
was it was bad two minutes of your old
sort of feels too bad and it kind of
looks very much like the HD re-release
of there too they did or I guess it's
just HD of all of them or whatever and
so I guess we'll see it looks like an
arcade game cuz I'm not still not sure
how much if there's some stuff look at
that look at him I love the framerate
mom yeah there was this was the there
was a bit of frame 80 problems
apparently with this uh with this
footage yeah i got my boards on fire
ripping it up i just watched that weird
movie about the australian skateboarders
last night i would so my look at that
guy he's it hey do a manual do manual i
hope they have a kickflip competition
and video in this one as well there was
already pretty pretty sick back in the
day September 29th NBA 2k16 I always
find a weird they released them then
like kind of when the season's over like
before it starts again I feel like it's
a real safe like holiday gift
parents to get kids right right so like
violent shooter almost sports the future
next year already okay Billy off the
couch inspire him at some time in
September we're gonna get a drift as
well there's no date on not yet but
that's all we know so far did either you
guys failure drifted III yeah
interesting a little bit okay that
moving on october sixth rock band 4 mmm
the black yeah guitars and [ __ ] or if
it's rock band you're talking about then
all of them drums and everything we've
got a room full of drugs there's no
Chester to scale it look at them I'm
believe it I wonder how often people
think Nick is Clippy because they do
have that sort of still a little grin on
their face I feel like if he's always
got a chainsaw in his time instead of a
guitar though rock by for from harmonix
you guys interested in this or guitar
hero live I'm interested in watching
other people have fun with it I suck at
these games I didn't really have much
fun playing but of these game I like
watching people get into it yeah I got
into like guitar hero with like one was
popular in like with me in college oh
yeah totally total blast cuz it was easy
to put on and play and put blast it
blasted black tunes hot vids get blasted
no I mean totally bra I'm so I the
minute they announced that I was coming
out I was like [ __ ] I live on I like a
second-floor apartment now oh yeah up
for so I'm like put down to make extra
yeah because I was all about that we're
just shut up up there with the kids yeah
I'm we'll see and october ninth
uncharted the nathan drake collection HD
re-releases still common 2015 octobre 13
Tom Clancy's Rainbow six seed you played
a bit of this rom right we did yeah
alpha um I think they're coming back
soon with an with another one it's Lee a
lot of office invaders for this it was
fun I think it started off with a great
I mean it's just you know such a team
centric game and yeah that's what's
really great in the office was you get
to like kind of collaborate but a couple
times I played solo I remember at Grand
its alpha all speculation but I remember
a couple times was like all right this
is getting a little repetitive yeah I
needed none that a kick some kind of
like motivation I mean again it's just
like you know they only show off like
one map too much yeah portable as
it's interesting because it's the same
sort of thing we're like I know like
loads of people the office played
evolved back in the day like earlier
this year actually and that was you know
super fun for all you guys came out it
just didn't like catch on like nobody
was playing it out I saw Chris waters
playing last week I was shocked oh
really keep something painful yes yes Oh
time fo I got it seems later yeah yeah
and moving on guitar hero live October
20th hot on the heels of am rock band 4
actually I skipped one Yoshi's woolly
world yeah exactly I just want the
amoeba [ __ ] hell [ __ ] God like I
spent a hundred work 30 bucks in that
stupid pitboy ding ah-me bows gun down
october twenty third Assassin's Creed
syndicate it's another set it's another
Assassin's Creed grapple and and GTA
like racing on carts and stuff yep just
like GTA drive-bys in Victorian London
or post-industrial London I'm i love
this series so much i like some of the
old games are like best favorite games
of the the last generation of consoles
I'm just I don't know what it is I I
think if I even saw a really good
Assassin's Creed game I'd be buzzed for
but something about this one even in
particular it's just like knock grab a
meal I am so tired of hoods and cloaks
and leaping and climbing and contextual
controls just [ __ ] end it powerful
marriage it's stupid kid it's a it's
gonna be interesting i'm sure to a lot
of sauce the screen phones to let their
but yeah like I feel like your guys
sentiments are when you ask just general
people about this that nobody is really
getting excited about anymore it'll be
interesting to see if they do this this
is all I want just running over see
aliens you should get going I'm an
assassin I'm doing it for some sort of
greater good Jew Oh God darn it my lamp
post yeah the next week or actually that
same week I think within four days
October 27th halo 5 yeah y Thien yeah
excited about that you speaking my
language yeah you're a big halo fan you
excitement got huge halo fan always have
been I've bought an xbox like four times
probably my life for
that halo of course was in the for xbox
you buy an xbox for every single halo
yes and then twice we're dedicated and
then twice wonder I got the red ring oh
yeah for the 360 but anyways um last
year was are obviously the worst year to
be a halo fan when Master Chief
collection so this is like I'm so
excited because as far as I play the new
game mode war zone is such a refresh
from like four which is toliet it was
fun but I got tiresome when it was like
all right stop trying to milk a call
duty ask no yeah air drops or excuse me
ordinance drops and all that stuff here
you have war zone which is like I don't
feel desk yeah like it's chaotic and it
was real I I played like two rounds but
you could see it being really fun you
know and then you hear they're also just
making a lot of great moves um except
for one which is the no longer can you
split screen co-op Oh [ __ ] really
yeah that's a big letdown cuz I've done
that every year but sarcasm that's a
shame there's a little bit of shame for
some people but um you hear stuff like
you know no future DLC maps will be um
paid for yeah that's all free I'm not
like they're just making cool moves and
I like I'm sure they'll have their own
deal see a plan for her but like I don't
been getting on Destiny's our slaw
recently but I like they're just seems
whenever halo comes out halo is a game
that has just so much so many modes in
it yeah like that I member 13 k mad and
had a lot Ford stuff and a multiplayer
and then our own campaign like you
always feel like you've gotten your sort
of money's worth out of halo and I'm not
a huge fan but yeah the war zone stuff
looks looks interested really weird for
me it's non sequitur real quick anytime
a halo game comes out keep it like a
month that game is half price yeah that
is one of the biggest triple-a games to
drop its price tag out of any other
series that I know I think it must be
because Microsoft have like coin and
that I wonder if it's like a loss leader
for them setting the controller know
exactly yeah but it just it plots so
fast dozen beers of war yeah yeah but
like when for came out it took like a
few weeks for to be done in like 40
bucks yeah oh so hold on your cash kids
use that use I use that Christmas money
at WWE 2k16 also at that day good show
if you second stone coals on the box man
dick shows on the wrestler I know we
interviewed him last year gamescom yeah
we maybe we'll do it again this year
love to see at know
third need for speed is ash I think I
know is that that day as well the latest
one and november six call of duty black
ops 3 yeah Blops i play a bunch of times
actually unless you know opposed to an
advanced warfare which in beginning i
was like oh this is great you know the
old all this you know crazy mobility
stuff and then you get black ops and
it's it's not as messed out okay or
you're just like people are just totally
it's like all right let's let's ground
the shooter again that's what halos
doing perfectly again its or their early
snapping it so it's like all right you
get one boost and it's slow recharge
yeah they're doing the same thing with
black ops you know slow movement the
clam brings great and that there's also
that total overwatch you know power
player just kind of modes where it's
like yeah you know there's like cool
moves were the one my favorite is a
glitch which was this move we're like
you know you um you basically work
backwards like five seconds kind of like
that yet I like the lady in overwatch
tracer tracer yeah it's interesting cuz
i played a preview of this glitch and I
remember telling the devs like dude like
own this down it's so terrifying cuz
that in the beginning like when I first
thought it was just the guy would just
disappear immediately yeah you wouldn't
no idea where he was so you did screwed
cuz I now if i use it i know you are now
they have a little bit of the tracer
elements you can kind of get a gist of a
direction yeah direction um so I like
it's gonna good I mean it's you know
again live call duty games I'll play for
a period of time yeah and I feel like
black ops is the one that the online
community for two is still so high that
they kind of need to pull I feel like
this is them dragging people kicking and
screaming from the xbox 360 over to ya
over text box when or ps3 to ps4 and
moving on though November 10th what a
banger rise of the tomb Raider's ash so
it's fun I've got down for you guys I
was so excited about this I've been
playing that stupid I got 109 people on
my stupid iOS vol thing oh man I've been
playing that a lot too yeah but this is
just I cannot wait like what a treat for
them to show the game offered of the
show off all the stuff they've added to
it this terrifying nonsense
or your wife or husband is looking over
your shoulder and then for it to be
coming at like three months later like
we're almost almost there already it's
gonna be such a time sucker for me I
love like I watched you know I think it
didn't get chance to watch it live
because we were you know frantically
cutting these up hmm but I remember
watching you again and being so blown
away by that one line where he said uh
when the the kind of Jarvis Cesc robot
says your name he's like we've
pre-loaded a thousand common names yeah
you know say your name if you type it in
like that just a small small little
clicks like that yeah it really doing
all right port is gonna work that bar
like my own sound good my child is also
named bort I wonder if you'll find board
license plates around the waistline hey
yeah it's it's a fully voiced as well so
god damn it maybe we'll get our first
two discs gain no actually we're one cuz
you're just downloaded oh I got the
collectors man yeah oh really I thought
it had me too we're gonna look like
dorks are secondary experiences and the
next week november seventeenth star wars
battlefront i'm not really a big star
Wars fan I do like battlefield but I
fallen off the past couple years but god
dammit this link game looks absolutely
crazy cool looking so if there's one
thing you could talk cuz I got to play
this it was I last time I was on his
couch I didn't like it cuz I feel like
gameplay video and yeah they kind of
yeah didn't show much when you guys so
right and then I played it and there are
just certain things that you can file
away into a cabinet and be like this is
going to be great it's gonna look
awesome it's gonna sound awesome it is a
star wars game I that's where I really
got like it feels like Star Wars he felt
like it um look at his [ __ ] it was
really fun the I had the couple of
gripes and I think of deaths at spoken
are already on it which were like the
flying hmm is is really Jenky um I will
be playing this on PC just because I'm a
huge flight nerd so I'll just like have
my joystick I will be compatible but the
controls of that were I crashed so often
couldn't get a kill off by working with
buddy blames his tools man yeah but
engine in general it was really fun I
enjoyed it I think yeah they do a great
job of showing liked it with the Caspian
Border stuff of battlefield 3 and multi
force gameplay they do a great job of
showcasing this it'll be as with any
game that has
many types of vehicles is going to be
really interesting to see if they can
balance it out but man it looks pro tip
you can't take down a TIE fighter with a
pistol god I can keep trying man you
never know it'll be like Battlefield 4
you'll just they'd couches in that game
you can shoot from and stuff no world
the world but they have been her fat
yeah there's no social moon god amun and
later that month 26th just in case you
didn't have enough hot bangers
TrackMania turbo comin at ya console
track Manny nope just me okay and also
november and XCOM 2 we don't know when
yet but XCOM 2 is gonna come any any
fans of the old ex con games or the
earth so much you're right now I didn't
love them they're good game so I don't
have a personal tent I love them I loved
all the old ones I love Tara from the
deep UFO defense or and all those
there's a couple of dodgy third-person
ones in the middle but yeah when they
when they remade and I thought I was
like one of the best remakes in recent
memory I was a jagged alliance guy back
oh really oh yeah and no jagged lines
coming out this year sorry Peter bran
and December just when you think all the
video games are out there's a couple of
little more dribbles out of the video
game facio December first talk about
that Chum Bucket Just Cause 3 Avalanche
got something left in the tank Just
Cause 3 yeah surprising i played one
play a little bit of two um not as huge
fans this one of sync works like right
rather be playing GTA sometimes i get
that once well I like I bet I actually
played three for a while oh yeah with
the debug menu in it and holy [ __ ] is
that game fun when you can just like I'm
gonna spawn anywhere in the world I'm
gonna spawn all these weapons I'm and
all this and that like and the wingsuit
it now like you can it's just amazing
like you can grapple to a thing flick
yourself off of it go into the air and
and pretty much like Neverland if you're
really good mm-hmm I just execute like
spider mounting your way through the
road yeah yeah no I mean and your you
know your throne you just you can just
do all these crazy things like oh well
that's what sold me was like Victor when
he we started doing the combo of the
grapple moves that was what really took
me away I was like how he was doing all
those cool things he says it's been a
while since we've seen Rico Rodriguez on
this looks this looks like super this
you know what this is the perfect
December
this is the perfect I've got some time
off for the holidays I'm just gonna sit
at home on my ass eat like turkey and
and drink beer and just play a dumb game
that I don't really have to think about
very often hey here's a little [ __ ] it's
not too gonna do here hit the button
Rico we only only one sure Yap is gonna
lie nothing and make it explode maybe no
just go straight at December first
december for zen oblate Chronicles X is
out and then December eighth last big
release of the year and it's not really
a full release but it's coming out
there's the explosion there you go look
at that boom boom boom hey it doesn't
stop keeps on going premium December
eighth hit man's back agent 47 they're
releasing this game we're like a bunch
of missions in it it's not like the hell
it's a full-price game like I don't know
how many but that's it for the sake of
argument say quarter half the missions
then I'm gonna be releasing the missions
later in here some sort of weird early
access type scenario and you guys hit
man fans they released this traitor eat
I can't think of a more generic ass
character really I gets I have such a
softie yes like I don't know I'm a big
fan of the old get like I've played them
all okay maybe not the the camera before
last but big fan of him I wanted to your
blood money is absolutely spectacular
but yeah it's just something about the
the Tobias Reaper character the age of
47 Gargery sort of doesn't really play
anymore it's not exciting at all it's so
boring to look at that guy that game is
fun like the games are gone they're like
little Sun boxes to like murder folks if
I'm gonna get hooked into a series
that's existed for so long you know when
sort of like sticks with the same thing
like I needed there to be something
different to grab me and usually that's
like a character right or a setting this
is just the same character the same
settings so like if Assassin's Creed was
out I year for these past 12 games like
where we've been after a while no I was
just that's why the same before every
it's fair for you can assassin has a
hood and a cloak and a dagger and a shut
up maybe it's a different age and every
time it's all got alopecia yeah I guess
we'll find out later in the air and
before I let you guys go what is the
game you're most looking forward to in
2015 Rob first of all it's halo yeah oh
yeah I just want it it's one of those
things two words like man if this
doesn't go as well as
hope it's gonna be like bummer about you
got some other games look forward to
though if it doesn't work out yeah Peter
what about yourself it's all metal gear
oh yeah yeah sorry I keep hitting my leg
approaching crew no one will be read a
bit more Yeah right kids love that yeah
no metal gear is going to be such a a
massive game it is you know the missing
chapter and the entire like storyline of
metal gear solid and the original metal
gear and I'm just I'm ready to see how
they title together yeah and it's less
than two months away yeah freaking out
cuz there's like a hundred our game and
I'm doing the review so great yeah one
it'll be like Kevin with the witcher
you'll just have to stay home for all
the attack i'll be at PAX Prime in the
hotel really I don't know we'll see it
well I don't know how we're gonna get
the game or not and my game i'll
probably looking forward to more than
all of them is fallout 4 it's a turns
out this year is pretty great for video
games at does any game that we failed to
mention all right again the came out
earlier this year that you're looking
forward to or if one of the games we
talked about just now tickles your fancy
let us know what you think is the best
game coming at 2015 in the comments
below video games
you